yeah what's up guys my name is luciano
and i just wanted to make an
announcement video to let you know what
i'm doing with minecraft server because
i'm getting really sick of ftp crashing
all the time and i'm not sure if it's a
problem with the host
or if it's a problem with actually you
know actual ftb
because i don't know i've googled all
these issues and it doesn't seem that
many people are having them so i don't
know
if ftb servers like if there are other
ftp servers that's completely flawless
but my one keeps crashing and i'm not
sure if it's the host or the actual ftp
code so what i'm going to do right now
is my current host is multiplayer
since the month of multiplayer is going
to run out in about a week or so
week and a half um i'm just going to pop
on
bucket normal vanilla minecraft with
bucket
um onto the ip address that you'll see
in the description instead of the ftp
server i've or i've i will keep the map
and everything for the ftp server don't
worry
but um for now i want to switch it to
bucket and
um we'll see if that works all right so
you can join the link is in this in the
description
go on it you know build some stuff for
fun
um i don't know just play around with it
i will save that world as well so don't
don't be afraid to build something big i
i'll definitely save it um and
you know we'll see if it crashes if it
does crash and if it continually crashes
then i will definitely switch hosts
there are a lot of australian hosts to
choose from so don't worry about that
um and um and yeah i guess we'll see
what happens because
a lot of you people have actually been
like donating to me and everything
um to run the server i'm just really
kind of pissed that ftb keeps crashing
all the time so
um i will do whatever i can whatever is
in my power to actually make sure that
we can run an ftp server if that's go i
don't even know if you guys want an ftb
server over a normal minecraft server
let me know
but um that's sort of what's going on
with minecraft server right now
so um again the link is in the the
server app is in the description go
ahead and click on that and i'll see you
guys later
bye